today on the Matt Walsh show the
government is now arresting pastors who
try to hold church services meanwhile
abortion clinics have been deemed
essential by state governments across
the across the country and also a
federal judge multiple federal judges
have said that's essential so they stay
open this is what America has become
close the the churches down keep the
abortion clinics open we'll talk about
all this also 5 headlines including more
mayors and governors around the country
are going insane with power and it's
like they're trying to one-up each other
with just how insane they get and today
we'll cancel a speaking of which of the
mayor of Houston who tried to solve
crime by asking criminals nicely to stay
home and not commit crime so all of that
coming up on the way before we get to
any of it though very important I want
to tell you about our good friends over
at fairway meat market you know I think
this is a really a perfect time to be to
be talking about this and and to you
know order some some product from
fairway meat market yourself especially
because you know you don't want to go
out of the house maybe you don't want to
go to the grocery store people aren't
exactly practicing perfect social
distancing over at the grocery store so
you can order the meat you could freeze
it if you want to and it still tastes
great even when you freeze it I know
that's what that's what I have been
doing fairway meat markets quality meat
comes straight from America's heartland
premium beef and all-natural pork is
raised by family farmers and sourced
straight out of a corn country giving
you access to the highest quality meat
in America people love the wide
selection of products you can find at
fairway ribs - rib eyes pork chops beef
tenderloin if every style and cut that
your kitchen can handle by the way I've
had all of those rib rib eye pork chop
beef tender it's all it's all fantastic
so if you want to enjoy this delicious
food yourself all you have to do go to
fairway meat market calm you select your
favorite meat products and you just
stand by your grill waiting patiently
for them to show up it's as simple as
that this week my listeners get the
heartland package valued at 230 bucks
for just $99.99 plus free shipping when
entering Walsh at checkout the Heartland
package includes eight 8-ounce
all-natural boneless pork chops six
eight ounce USDA choice ribeye steaks
and then one
mouth-watering side dish as well that's
more than 50% off the best meat in
America Plus free shipping
that's fairway meat market calm promo
code Walsh and look for the heartland
package okay by the way I I do want to
mention this before we get into all the
churches being closed down everything
you know you see you've probably seen
these headlines in the last couple of
days
here's one from Vox now these headlines
are all over the place although all the
big media companies have it says the
coronavirus has now killed more
Americans than the 9/11 terror attacks
this is interesting to me that you see
these headlines because we've been told
over and over again
we've been screamed at really actually
that it's illegitimate and wrong and
misguided to compare coronavirus deaths
to flu deaths so the flu kills sixty
eight eighty thousand americans a year
sometimes more sometimes less and we've
been told no you can't do that can't
compare it can't make like a business
they're totally different they're so
different that any comparison just could
not possibly be helpful but then the
same media that tells us that we can't
make those comparisons they turn around
and compare the coronavirus to 9/11 now
wait a second hang on hang on he isn't a
terrorist attack more different from the
corona virus then the flu is from the
corona virus however different the
corona virus and the flu are aren't they
closer aren't they more similar at least
than 9/11 which comparison is closer
which is more legitimate which is more
illuminating which of these two things
are more similar a terrorist attack
where people fly building planes into
buildings and a virus or a virus and a
virus which of those groups have more
similarities so why is it that the less
similar group the more strained
comparison ends up in the headlines
while the more legitimate comparison is
anathema and really you're not allowed
to I mean up until this 9/11 thing if
you haven't noticed you you're not you
up until now you haven't been allowed to
make any comparisons between the corona
virus and any other disease
anything if you try to compare it to
anything else the swine flu polio I mean
any any any kind of attempt of
comparison you try to make it the
Spanish flu right it said no it's no
good you can't compare to that can't
compare to that don't know no totally
different totally different
oh but 9/11 yeah well they've now those
two things yeah now we can really now
make that comparison put it in the
headlines well why is the one allowed
the other not well we know why because
the 9/11 comparison makes the corona
virus seem scarier and therefore it's
okay but any come any comparison that
has the effect of making the corona
virus seem a little bit less scary is
not okay okay now moving on it so it's
come to this a pastor has been arrested
for holding a church service in the
United States of America okay it's not a
headline from China this is happening
right now in America let me read from
the Christian Post says pastor rodney
howard-browne leader of revival
international ministries and the river
and the river at Tampa Bay Church in
Tampa Florida was arrested Monday for
what officials say was the violation of
a safer at home order which prohibits
large worthless worship services during
the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
Hillsborough County Sheriff Chad
Chronister said that when he saw images
of a crowded Sunday service at the
church he was furious and he's angry and
he's the anisa he's the sheriff so he
can just arrest you because he's mad
right we received an anonymous tip that
dr. rodney howard-browne refused a
request to temporarily stop holding in
large gatherings at his church he said
and instead he was encouraging his large
congregation to meet at his church
Hillsborough County issued a safer at
home order effective March 27th the
order mandates non-essential businesses
to abide by the CDC's social distancing
guidelines if they're unable to do that
they have to shut down Howard brand
churches are non-essential it's been
determined across the country in one
fell swoop
we're just saying churches not essential
Howard Brown argued that his church is
an essential business and that the order
violates his First Amendment rights
seems like he'd have a case the pastors
sort of shows that he was charged with
unlawful assembly and violation of
public health emergency rules which are
both second-degree misdemeanors
punishable up to 60 days in jail and a
maximum fine of $500 Chronister says our
goal is to not is not to stop people
from worshipping but the safety and
well-being of our community must always
come first
it's a shame that someone has taken
advantage of this for whatever reason
I just don't understand it the only
reason I can see is it's a reckless
reason to put your parishioners in
jeopardy Chronister says I believe
there's nothing more important than
faith in a time like this and as a
Sheriff's Office we would never impede
someone's ability to lean on their
religious beliefs but practicing those
beliefs has to be done safely practicing
those beliefs has to be done safely you
can have your First Amendment rights you
can practice your religion the most
sacred right the right that's its Givens
right there given pride of place first
amendment in the Bill of Rights you can
have it but only if it's safe if it's
deemed unsafe then then then it's the
First Amendment out the window
everything's out the window and the
government will make an example of you
now before we talk more about this I
want to throw something else onto the
pile something else to consider reading
this from Politico says federal judges
on Monday lifted restrictions Texas Ohio
knob al Alabama imposed on abortion
during the corona virus pandemic and
decisions that could have ripped
repercussions for several more
republican-led states that have deemed
the procedure non-essential during the
crisis I think it goes on from there
Texas Ohio Alabama different district
judges have said that no this is
essential you're not allowed to close
down the abortion clinics and there are
many other states that have already that
are led by Democratic governors that
have already said from the beginning
abortion clinics and stay one so borscht
clinics are essential they stay open
meanwhile churches across the country
have been deemed non-essential and are
closed at gunpoint and if you gather for
worship you could be arrested abortion
clinics essential worship non-essential
one close
open I mean how can we tolerate this how
how can this be justified and I see
plenty of so-called conservatives who
seem to be basically okay with this it's
it's if anyone had told you six months
ago that we would be here right now
where pastors are being arrested for
holding church services in America and
that the government has essentially all
it all at once circumvented the First
Amendment simply by declaring churches
non-essential and not only that would be
happening but that many conservatives
would say well okay it's all that keep
us safe you wouldn't believe it
well maybe the second part of that you
would believe conservatives being
cowardly and dumb enough to go along
with this kind of thing without question
that part you probably believe if you if
you if you if you've been around the
conservative movement for any length of
time but the rest of it it is it is
almost unbelievable but it's really
happening talk more about this in just a
second before we do a quick word from
beard supply you know if you're sitting
at home and you're trying to grow the
Quarantine beard first of all shame on
you for waiting until quarantine to grow
a beard but if that's what you're doing
then listen you also need to make sure
that you're keeping good hygiene and
that you're making sure the beard looks
good I wouldn't judge you now if you
want everything else about your
appearance and your life to fall to
pieces during this that's fine right and
if look I haven't changed out of sweat
pants in in in six and a half days so if
that that part's perfectly okay
everything else about you can fall to
pieces but the beard you have to keep on
point and that's that's that's got at
least at least that at least have that
much pride and that's what beard supply
can help you with beard supply helps
keep your beard healthy itch free soft
smelling great and more than ten
thousand beards agree and you know ten
thousand beards altogether I think one
beard can't be wrong but certainly ten
thousand altogether certainly cannot be
wrong so whatever you're looking for
each beard supply beard oil is
handcrafted from 100% natural
ingredients no synthetics no mass-market
essentials
no no paraffin
I don't even know what that is but
there's none of that in there if you're
worried about the paraffin this stuff is
basically just squeezed right out of the
earth and then it goes right into your
beard so for a short time beard supply
is offering Matt Walsh o listeners 25%
off just go to beard supply comm use the
promo code Wolfe again that's a beard
supply.com use promo code Walsh all
right um
now one other thing about the abortion
clinics so the borscht clerks are
allowed to stay open how does an
abortionist practice social distancing
from a mother while he's killing her
child can he stay six feet away while
doing that I mean I've never been in the
room for an abortion but I'm I don't how
does the abortion abortionist stay six
feet away from the mother while doing
that but it doesn't matter because you
know it doesn't make a lot of sense to
me it might not make sense to you it
doesn't have to make sense to us we have
entered a point where the government can
make whatever rules they want regardless
of the Constitution and they can enforce
those rules at gunpoint and that's what
we're seeing happening across the
country these government officials and
at every level governor's mayor's we
talked yesterday the Board of
Commissioners in a County and what
Indiana making up rules all of these
different levels of government they just
make whatever rule they want it doesn't
have to comply with the Constitution
doesn't have to make sense it doesn't
have to be something that could could
demonstrably actually succeed in slowing
the spread of the virus if they decide
that hey we don't want this then they're
gonna say we don't want it you can't do
it
now this is almost beside the point but
I want to show you this a screenshot
from the livestream of the church
service that got this pastor arrested
there in Florida here's a screenshot
here's here's the the worship service
last Sunday
are those congregants six feet apart no
okay but he did say you had them grouped
according to family members and you know
families coming in of course they're
gonna be together but there's going to
be space in between each
group of families that come in now the
pastor also says that he was given out
hand sanitizer and that the staff that
was dealing directly with the carrier
congregants they were all wearing gloves
I you know I don't I can't vouch for the
truth of that but we can see that there
is some spacing there in the in the in
the building here's my point those
groups of people are separated more then
they would be in the checkout line at
the grocery store yet I can still go
into the grocery store for a bag of
chips and wait in line with twenty other
people six inches apart I can do that
the government says that's essential if
I want to go to a grocery store six
times a day right for whatever I want I
can do that buying chips at the grocery
store that's essential going to church
is not I happen to disagree I think
church is a whole lot more essential
than a bag of chips government if
government officials though I've decided
based on their own priorities based on
their own preferences their own opinions
that attending church could not ever be
more essential than whatever reason
reason a person might have to go to a
grocery store and they can impose that
subjective viewpoint on the population
at gunpoint as all this is happening I
keep thinking about that Benjamin
Franklin quote that is so popular right
normally it's quite popular and the
quote you know those who would give up
Essential Liberty to purchase a little
temporary safety deserve neither liberty
nor safety the interesting thing about
that quote is it's so popular and you
see it everywhere during normal times
but when it comes time for that
mentality and that philosophy to
actually be put into action all of a
sudden no no it's out the window we now
we ripped those bumper stickers off of
our cars and hide them under the bed
stuffed them in the closet and then so
that we can proceed to give up our
Liberty for safety and then once the
threat goes away we take the bumper
stickers out we slap them on the bumper
again and we say
give me liberty or give me death i I
just if that if this principle this
philosophy that we as Americans pretend
to live by pretend to believe in if that
doesn't apply to this situation then
when would it ever apply see the thing
is you might say well this is an
exception but the people who are giving
up safety or giving up liberty for
safety they always think it's an
exception they're always going to say
that now I feel like I have to keep
stipulating and keep saying over and
over again and there's no point in even
saying it because people who want to
misinterpret me if they're if you are
determined to misinterpret me then
you're gonna go ahead and do that I know
it doesn't matter what I say but I am
NOT suggesting that this virus is a hoax
or that it's not serious or that people
aren't dying from it or that we
shouldn't take it seriously I am NOT
saying that what I am saying though is
that it is madness to intentionally
plunge into a great depression and make
millions of people destitute for the
sake of this and the Constitution still
exists and we can't just put it on hold
and we can't give government officials
the power and the authority to make up
whatever rules they want for as long as
they want imposing their preferences and
priorities and opinions on us at
gunpoint we can't do that so that that's
that
my basic position we should still retain
our our essential human liberties and we
should do whatever we can to avoid a
Great Depression which will result in
the destitution of millions and
suffering and misery unlike anything we
can conceive right now those two things
while also taking the virus seriously
and that is all possible that is
actually possible there are basic things
we could do as I've been saying a
million times I'll say it again you keep
the nursing homes quarantine elderly and
sick people you keep them quarantined
right you-you-you allow people to go
back to work but maybe you encourage or
hell if you want to mandate gloves fine
in certain industries masks okay
something like barber shops okay maybe
you maybe you mandate for a period of
time that if you're going to a barber
shop or if you if you work at a barber
shop or a hair salon you wear a mask now
I know you're gonna tell me well that
doesn't that doesn't guarantee you could
still spread the virus I know you could
still spread it but let me ask you this
if two people if you had a barber and
someone go into a barber shop both of
them don't have any symptoms and don't
tell me well they could still have the
virus without symptoms I know that okay
but we're talking probability here you
got a barber you got a person neither of
them have symptoms they're both wearing
masks the guys getting a haircut
takes 15 minutes or whatever however
however long it takes what is the chance
that a virus will be transmitted during
the course of that interaction both
masks and neither have symptoms you
don't have to tell me it's possible it
could still happen I know it's possible
what's the chance though what is the
probability what is this distal
likelihood of that happening and is it
high enough to justify putting thousands
of barbershops out of business forever
which is what we're doing right now I'm
just using barbershops as one example
that's a
question it's a fair question we should
be asking and I don't want to hear a
responsive you're gonna kill your
grandma all the grandma shut up with
that I don't want to hear the emotional
please this is too serious for that I'm
asking basic questions fair questions
about things like statistical
probability and weighing risk and reward
that's what I am interested in I'm not
interested in your emotional Appeals
because there's a lot at stake right now
and putting millions of businesses out
of business forever and having 40
million people unemployed in the span of
a month that is a serious consequence
and if you think that you whoever you
are watching this if you think that you
are going to apply through this and
you're not gonna feel it you will as I
said yesterday there are a few people
maybe who can go through something like
an economic crash or a Great Depression
and and feel unaffected by it or maybe
even profit off of it but you almost
certainly are not one of those people
and so you're gonna suffer too and your
family will and your loved ones question
I've been asking all along risk reward
calculation what we're doing right now
is it worth the price that everybody is
going to pay
is there another way of doing this a way
that would mitigate to at least to some
significant extent the risk of
transmitting the virus while also
hopefully standing off a great
depression I think there are other ways
we're not even considering those ways
and that to me is insanity that is
lunacy it is I feel like I'm surrounded
by lunatics more and more each day there
are a few of us out here screaming this
I mean
all right let's move on to let's move on
to headlines
well more states of course have jumped
into the shelter at home pool and just
yesterday in fact there were a bunch of
other states Virginia led the charge
Virginia's governor blackface Ralph has
instructed residents of the state to
stay home until June 10th he explained I
want to be clear do not go out unless
you need to go out this is very
different than wanting to go out so if
you just want to go out blackface Rael
says you can't go out you better have an
approved reason to exit your domicile
Northam has also made it clear that if
you need more shoe polish though for
your face then that of course is a very
good reason to go out so that that will
be approved meanwhile the state of
Maryland where I was born raised my
beloved in Maryland has gone into a full
shutdown also telling people to stay
home Governor Hogan said we are no
longer asking or suggesting that
Marylanders stay home we are directing
them to do so now here's a question of
ponder how many businesses can survive
for two months two and a half months all
said and done with zero revenue
blackface ralph wants to keep everybody
in their homes cowering in a corner
until June 10th what will they be
walking out into when they emerge from
their homes what kind of economy will be
left for them how many of those people
who are sheltering in their homes how
many of them when they leave their homes
are gonna have a job to go to are gonna
have a way to feed their families how
many does that not matter apparently it
doesn't matter we're not even thinking
about that
yeah well we'll worry about that later
again total madness collective insanity
we are doing something as a nation that
we have never done before we have never
shut down the country before like this
ever for anything does the threat
justify it this is the most dramatic
response we've ever had to anything is
it the worst threat we've ever faced is
it even the worst virus the worst
disease we've ever faced
the absolute worst if not why is it
getting the strongest reaction there's
another question if this is not the
worst threat we've ever faced as a
nation
it's not then why are we reacting in a
way unlike we've ever reacted before to
anything number two yesterday the Empire
State building's official Twitter
account which by the way of all the
buildings I think the Empire State
Building has the best has the best
Twitter account
great great memes the empire state
building posts actually I don't know
that I want to fall but it they posted a
tweet the building posted between the
building said we'll never stop shining
for you starting tonight through the
Cova nineteen battle our signature white
lights will be replaced by the heartbeat
of America with a white in red and with
a white and red siren in the mast for
heroic emergency workers on the front
line of the fight
okay so sounds inspiring right well
let's take a look at what this actually
looked like here it is here's the here's
the siren on top of the Empire State
Building and remember they're not trying
to scare you none of this is about
scaring you you see that right there
wait it's it's literally something out
of a dystopian young adult novel what
you're seeing right there and I'm
constantly seeing that this I saw this
online someone posted it and my first
reaction was that's a joke that no way
they're not really doing that are they
they didn't really convert the Empire
State Building into a giant siren
lighting up the night sky in this
terrifying way in a city that's already
that's already petrify didn't really do
that no way and then I go check oh yeah
no they they really did it that really
happened number three let's focus on
something positive though Kate Winslet
is well she played an epidemiologist in
a movie once
so naturally Sky News they went to ask
her for medical advice and Winslet was
more than happy to oblige this is what
she had to say in the movie Contagion
I paid an epidemiologist trying to stop
the spread of a hypothetical virus to
prepare for the role I spent time with
some of the best public health professor
in the world and what was one of the
most important things they taught me
wash your hands like your life depends
on it because right now in particular it
just might all the lives of someone you
love
or even the life of someone you might
not know that is still deserving of your
consideration like the people on the
front lines of this fight right now the
doctors and the health care providers
the people who are still working in the
grocery stores or delivering food to
your homes which is where you should be
right now but wait a second didn't wince
let's character die in that movie see
see my thing is we should be listening
to the characters who lived shouldn't we
or is this I you know I learned the hard
way I learned a lesson the hard way so
you don't have to is it that kind of
thing I don't know by the way um it's
good that she's that she's a mining all
of her vast fake experience to give us
advice and on that note I just wanted to
mention that when I was five years old I
drew a picture of myself in a rocket
ship and so for that reason tomorrow
I'll be delivering a 90-minute lecture
on astronomy and cosmology so what look
out for that number four I'm gonna show
you something
and then I'll give you the context but
first I want to show it to you so here
it is see all those many cars traffic
jam stretching miles it looks like what
do you think those cars are doing where
could they all be going
during these quarantines well this is in
Pittsburgh and those cars are waiting in
line at a food bank okay that's after
two weeks that's after two weeks of a
shutdown and you've got a you've got a
line of cars stretching to the horizon
of people who don't have food and need
to go to a food bank what do you think
it looks like
another week from now two weeks three
weeks two months how long is that line
of cars and how many people get fed up
in waiting for a first for ten hours in
line for food and then resort to other
means to get it number five and the DC
mayor mayor Bowser has seen all these
other mayors playing dictator and
decided that she doesn't want to be left
out in the cold anymore so she has
decided that anyone found outside their
home could go to jail for 90 days found
outside your home you could go to jail
but the magnanimous Bowser a Dear Leader
Bowser she will allow you in her wisdom
in her generosity to exit your place of
residence for a few specified reasons
that here she is explaining what those
reasons are as I've said before the only
reason she should be leaving your home
are to buy groceries pick up medicine or
to exercise with your own family because
you have bit or because you have been
advised to seek medical attention or
because you are performing an essential
job personally I'm I'm overcome with
with gratitude that she would allow
people to leave their house for
something like exercise truly her mercy
knows no bounds thank you thank you oh
great Bowser Thank You Oakley no just Oh
merciful a beautiful Bowser we praise
you we praise you we praise you with all
the choirs of angels yes sir you're
telling us that you're telling us who
we're allowed to exercise with which I
mean obviously is not something that you
have any authority whatsoever to control
but we're not going to question that
we're not gonna question we will comply
because if we were to not comply if we
were to question your wisdom and your
authority then we would be personally
responsible for killing thousands of
people so because this is not the land
of the free anymore
freedom is scary it's a very scary thing
we prefer to run into the warm abre
embrace of tyranny we run to the
to-to-to tyrannies bosom and we clutch
so tightly to it
now let's go to your daily cancellation
fact before we do that I want to mention
to you again if you haven't had a
chance to check out all access live then
I want to encourage you to do that you
can go tonight 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific this is the more casual sort of
I don't even really want to call the
show but it's a something we're doing
where it's just a conversation you know
and if your daily Y remember originally
the plan was to open it up to all access
members and this wasn't this was
something we're gonna do months down the
road or weeks down the road but we've
moved up the timeline we've opened it up
to anyone who's a daily Y remember and
it's just a conversation you know it's
sort of a back and forth very casual and
it's a way of us sort of having a little
bit of companionship I suppose in the
middle of all the isolation so if you're
around tonight and you're looking for
something to do which we all are 8 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific tuna and join
us on the all-access live show over at
Daley wired.com and now for your daily
cancellations staying on the theme of
mayor's who are going to be canceling
the mayor of Houston he held a press
conference yesterday and during the
course of that press conference he had a
message that I don't know I'm somewhat
skeptical that this will have the result
he's hoping for but this is what he had
to say let me just make my plea until
the corona virus is resolved criminals
take a break okay stay home
okay stay home and don't commit any
crimes and that way they are stay safe
and out of jail and police officers will
stay safe and can go home to their
families okay so everybody chill crooks
criminals you chill wait till the corona
virus is over okay I could just imagine
right a crook at home watching this and
then his crook friend calls him and says
hey did you want to go out and commit
some crimes tonight you want to do a
little crime let's think we could do
some crime what do you think and then
the other one says you know what I mean
looking listen I know we're criminals
and everything it's what we do but I was
just watching the mayor and he had this
really great suggestions he he said
maybe we shouldn't commit any crimes at
least for the time being maybe we should
just chill and not do crimes and his
friend says wait wait wait sex do you
want to not do crimes you're saying you
don't want to do crimes yeah let's just
chill let's relax what's that
any crimes for now hey listen there will
always be crimes we can do later on
let's wait for the coronavirus thing to
pass and just be cool about it
actually now that I think about it I
really I really can't imagine that
conversation or anything like it
actually happening so it seems and I
know that many cities around the country
are trying to get around this but it
seems like you're really gonna have to
actually enforce the law
and when I say that I mean the the real
laws the important laws not the laws of
prohibiting people from jogging too much
or jogging with the wrong person not
even really the laws prohibiting people
from gathering for worship III think
those are the less important ones that
we that you just came up with out of
nowhere in the last few days but crimes
like you know crimes against stealing
assault that sort of thing I think
you're still gonna have to enforce those
yeah so the mayor of Houston therefore
is cancelled now let's move on to emails
and we've got a why I'm wrong email this
one is from Eric and this I'll be my
inbox and and my message is every day
I've got an email almost it's like
they're following a script it's this
exact thing over and over and over and
over again to the point where you it
almost seems as if it's the same person
sending it but it's not because we live
in a nation of parrots it will just
repeat whatever they're told to say so
this is this is Eric he says Matt I
understand you want to go to the movies
and restaurants again but is that worth
your grandma's life I've been very
saddened by the direction you've taken
on this
you were always a champion for the
pro-life cause now you would have people
die just for the economy lives are more
important than money Matt okay Eric I
was asking somebody this yesterday I
couldn't get a response maybe you could
help me out with this please explain to
me you say is going to the movies worth
my grandma's life the answer's no okay I
wouldn't kill my grandma to go to the
movies like my grandma was trying to
vent me from going to movies I wouldn't
kill her to go I wouldn't do that but
here's what I want you to explain Erik
if I go to the movies see under my
proposal under my plan that no one cares
about but anyway my idea here is that as
I as I as I have been saying and I've
already said again on this show we hope
it up the businesses let people who are
young and healthy go to work
keep the nursing home quarantine keep
the elderly quarantined if you have
pre-existing conditions you know you use
you stay stay away for now and then of
course it'd be much easier than to
provide you with with assistance if we
don't have to give everybody assistance
we can just give it we can it could be
more targeted in that way so if we do
that and people who have the illness we
do aggressively testing people who have
test positive okay they're gonna be
isolated for several weeks if we do that
and my grandma is quarantined in a
nursing home which is where she is right
now how does me going to the movies kill
her can you explain
give me the step by step process I go to
the movies
my grandma's hundreds of miles away in a
nursing home quarantined and still in
quarantine which I think that that's how
it should remain how does me being at
the movies
kill my grandma please explain the
connection between those two things give
me a step we got step one I go to the
movies and then down here like Step five
my grandma dies give me two three four
whatwhat's fill-in-the-blanks there
because it seems to me that what you
have here is not an argument this is not
rational thought that you're sharing
with me this is emotional manipulation
emotional blackmail it's just emotion
these are just your emotions that you're
spewing out onto the page without even
thinking about it and you have been
convinced that the only way the only way
to keep all of our grandmas alive is if
we all stay locked our house
indefinitely for as long as the
government says you've been convinced of
that because that's what you were told
it doesn't have to be that way and you
say I want people to die just for the
economy okay once again Eric what do you
think the economy is what is the economy
to you how would you define it because
as I understand the economy it is not
some separate detached organism or
entity that's just hanging out there
like a like a thing that we come and we
pay homage to oh the economy the economy
you know the economy is people we talk
about the economy we mean people's jobs
their livelihood the way they feed their
families their kids okay that's what the
economy is and so it's not the money
that I'm worried about what I'm worried
about
is the man who doesn't you can't make
any money now and therefore can't feed
his kids it's not his money I'm not
worried about no as money as an in am
and inanimate object
not even that probably it's just though
it's a number in his bank account a
number that's now down to zero so I'm
not worried about that I'm worried about
him and his kids and how they survive
you see that do you understand that do
you really not understand it I don't
know how else to explain it I'm not
worried about my money I'm still making
money okay I'm in the media now we media
relies on advertisers so we are by no
means exempt but as it stands right now
anyway we're doing okay I'm still making
an income and and that's fine so I'm not
worried about this is not about me and
my money believe it or not I actually am
concerned about the millions of people
the millions upon millions upon millions
of people who are right now either
destitute or on the verge of becoming it
did you see the line of cars after two
weeks in Pittsburgh waiting in line for
hours at a food bank I'm worried about
those people are you not what about them
do you care about them
and another question I have for you the
arguments you're giving me here what you
seem to be saying is shut down the
economy because somehow the economy is
different from people it's two different
things and you can shut down the economy
without affecting people it's what you
seem to think and we should do this
because lives are more important than
money so what you're giving me here are
a series of first of all
misunderstandings emotional appeals and
cliches like lives are more important
than money and straumann because I never
said the lives aren't more important
than money so that's a straw man
argument that's what you're giving me
but here's here's here's my question to
you the swine-flu ten years ago back in
2009 swine flu hit there was I think I'm
off the top of my head you can check me
on this Google but I think was about 60
million cases of swine flu 200,000 or so
hospitalizations and 12,000 people died
did you at the time call for the
shutting down of the entire economy to
save those 12,000 did you now I don't
know Eric but I and I guess I can't
assume this about you because I have no
idea but I'm gonna assume that you
didn't and the reason I assume you
didn't is because from what I could tell
nobody did in fact most people until
this happened most people didn't even
realize that the swine flu they
remembered a swine flu most people
didn't even realize that it killed
12,000 people I didn't even realize that
when I first heard a month ago about the
swine flu killed 12,000 in America I
said what 10 years ago no it didn't and
I looked it up sure enough it did see
when that hit we just what do we do we
did nothing we did basically nothing we
just continued living our lives and it
killed 12,000 people and we just kept on
living now
don't tell me that this is worse than
swine flu it's different it's not the
same I understand that it's not my point
now actually it's not worse than the
swine flu yet right now it's not but you
might say it's going to be worse than
the swine flu okay that's a projection
that's an assumption could you could be
right probably you are I'll grant you
that this is going to be worse than this
wine
fine that's not my point those 12,000
people they were human beings and it's
12,000 people and they died so were
their lives not not worth saving me why
didn't you even if 12,000 is is lower
than the ultimate death toll we're gonna
see with the coronavirus let's say the
coronavirus let's go with the worst-case
scenarios that were now being told
originally the worst-case scenario was
like 2 million in America now we're
being told that worst case scenarios
200,000 okay let's say that let's just
say worst case scenario corna virus
kills 200,000 people 12,000 is less than
that but still those are human beings
those are lives a lot of them why don't
you call for the economy to be shut down
for their sake
are they not worth it to you do you not
care about them do you not care about
those lives what's going on Eric explain
it to me whatever your answer is to that
think about that question why didn't you
call for the shutting down the entire
economy to save 12,000 people from the
swine flu whatever your answer is to
that question I'm sure the answer is not
I don't care about those people those
people are worth less than money you
know I'm sure that's not your answer I'm
sure you'll have some other answer don't
you so think about that and as you come
to understand your own motivations as to
why you didn't call for the shutting
down the economy to save 12,000 people
you might start to understand where I'm
coming from on the coronavirus just
something to think about and we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
and listening stay safe
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there